As any cat owner can tell you, these fuzzy furballs spend
a lot of time grooming themselves.
According to some studies,
up to a quarter of their waking hours.
Cat’s sandpapery tongues are covered in
sharp, little cones known as papillae.
Researchers wanted a closer look at how these papillae
actually help cats groom both their
outer and inner layers of fur.
So they created 3D scans of tongues from six species
of cats: the domestic cat, the bobcat,
the Cougar, snow leopard, tiger and lion.
Zooming in revealed that the papillae have
a U-shaped cavity at their tips, which has
a wicking effect and helps carry droplets of saliva
through that top layer of fur down to the cat's skin.
The scientists also filmed several cats grooming.
When they slowed down the footage, they noticed that
the cats flared their tongues so
the papillae were perpendicular to the surface
of the tongue, which maximizes how much fur
they came into contact with.
The researchers also used a thermal camera
and found that depositing saliva on their
skin helps the cats cool off if they get overheated.
The researchers also designed a hairbrush,
based on the shape and configuration of the papillae
on a cat’s tongue.
Compared to a regular hairbrush,
the brush tugged less and was easier to clean.
Beyond helping humans get tangles out of their hair
or cat fur out of their carpets,
the scientists say the brush could potentially help deliver
medicine or cleaning solution directly to cats’ skin,
which could help improve treatments for cat allergies.
For now, it’s a closer look at the surprisingly complex
every day routines of our fuzzy feline friends.